Speaker 1: We actually got some really good
economic news this morning that I want to
talk about a little bit. We are now at the
pandemic low for new unemployment claims. These
are reported weekly jobless claims. Another
two hundred and ninety three thousand people
filed new claims last week. That is the new
pandemic era low, and we've subsequently hit
lower and lower lows. The U.S. posted a much
larger than expected drop in initial unemployment
claims last week, bringing the numbers of those
newly unemployed back toward their pre-virus
pace. The Labor Department released jobless
claims this morning. Initial claims ended for
the week ended October nine. That's last week.
Two hundred and ninety three thousand was the
actual number of new jobless claims they were
expecting 320000 in terms of continuing claims
2.5 nine million versus two point sixty seven
million expected. These are the smallest number
of new filings since March of 2020, and jobless
claims have been inching closer and closer to
pre-pandemic levels. So there is a slowdown in
firings, layoffs and separations. Reopenings are
taking place. Demand for workers is resurging,
so there's a few different stories here.
First is there's the narrative from the right
about lazy people who now want to stay home and
collect enhanced unemployment. The enhanced
unemployment is, I believe it is over in all
states, although there may be some states that
still have funds left and are continuing it. But
at the federal level, the enhanced unemployment
is done. As predicted, there were relatively few
people who were literally saying I would rather
just collect unemployment than work. Although any
social insurance system is going to have some free
riders, we don't really care about free riders
as long as the system at the macro level
is well calibrated and achieves what it's
supposed to achieve. Enhanced unemployment
was actually one of the biggest saving graces
for millions of people during the pandemic. The
fact that there were some free riders, I'm sure,
doesn't really change that, but as expected. As it
is phasing out, people are getting back to work.
New jobless claims are going lower and lower
and lower and are almost indistinguishable now
from the numbers we were seeing shortly before
the pandemic. So we've almost zero to that out.
Number two point that's relevant here. There have
been those on the right now opportunistically
saying that vaccine requirements and mandates
are going to keep unemployment rates up because
people are going to say, Oh, I've got to be
vaccinated or, oh, I've got to be tested. No,
I'd rather not work unemployment or not. That
doesn't seem to be happening. It never passed the
sniff test to begin with, and it doesn't appear
to be happening as the new unemployment numbers
keep going lower, lower and lower. A few other.
There's actually a graph here that we can look at.
U.S. jobless claims reach fresh pandemic
era low As you can see, there was this
major major spike in April of 2020, where there
were between six and seven million new claims,
and those continued to decline five million,
four million then into the threes and twos.
We eventually got under the one million mark in
the summer, last summer, August of twenty, etc.
And basically with just a little bit
of a spike right at the start of 2021,
continuing to decline, going lower and lower.
Now it's not all rainbows and ginger snaps.
Yahoo Finance rates Even as the number of those
newly unemployed improves lingering concerns over
the coronavirus, keep a lid on further progress
in the recovery. Many individuals still on the
sidelines of the labor force. Demand for workers
has outpaced supply. Job openings are at a near
record high of more than ten point four million
in August, so there are still many jobs available.
Many jobs available. Rubella Farooqui, who is the
chief U.S. economist for High Frequency Economics,
wrote shortages are a severe constraint of
the labor market currently. Overall, the labor
labor market remains on a gradual path towards
pre-pandemic health. The slowdown in the pace of
job gains and still depressed participation
rates are reminders that the process will
take some time, which is fine. This is, we don't
know, in an economy as large as the United States
shocks to the system where things happen. As
quickly as that, which happened in March and
April of 2020 are rare and they're not good for
the economy. It's that those are the types of
things that cause further follow on calamities
of different kinds in terms of supply chain,
in terms of all the different things that we've
been talking about. So it would be expected that
as we hopefully gradually continue to see cases
decline, deaths decline in the United States,
that we would see the labor market recover. But
this, although these are the best numbers of the
pandemic so far, there are still limitations to
the economy now, next week, probably next week.
We're going to talk about wages because one of the
big kind of debates that has surfaced in terms of
we need workers and we can't get
them has been the right saying, well,
you can't get them because they're lazy
people collecting unemployment at home,
and they would prefer to do that. The left has
said this is an issue of you're not paying enough.
If you want to get workers free market right,
offer a higher wage and then you'll have more
people interested in working for you. We're going
to dig into the wage issue next week and look at
so-called various quality jobs high, medium and
low quality jobs as they're sometimes described.
We're still putting together all the data. We're
going to look at that next week, next week.
If you have a story to tell. About your
employment path and the decisions you made based
on unemployment insurance that was or was not
available right into info at David Pakman dot com